[Music]
did you see um this texas situation
going on with this young white kid going
up to a black family's door with a whip
and he just starts swatting at the door
it's kind of a crazy story behind it's a
crazy story so this little white kid
this little white kid starts whipping
the door the mom opens the door you go
you better get out of here with that
whip and then the kid does say nothing
and he just like walks away how old was
the kid like single digit age did they
catch him on like ring or something yeah
they got him in the ring cam so where
did he get a whip from you know exactly
right mom's from the whip store like
what is it casual your casual toys
getting whipped at home with that
that's over the tassels
yeah so they end up going outside they
see that he also may have scratched
their car with it because he was like
whipping [ __ ] on the way to the indiana
jones yes that's what i hope it is they
go to the the white boy's house with the
white family and it's the the black dad
is there and he's like yo your sunblock
get out here right now and then the
white dad comes out with a gun like
holstered and he's like well uh my boy
says that your boy jumped in the other
day and then they're like that can't be
true because our boy's 13 doesn't even
go to the same school like they just
think it's the most ridiculous thing and
then the dude
fires like a warning shot
like next to him so they [ __ ] shoot
the roof and stuff
it's worse than that it's working his
little daughter was so close to it when
he shot it she didn't get hit his own
daughter his own daughter yeah his own
daughter so he shoots a warning shot
so then he gets arrested family not that
smart huh yeah and now that guy is
currently in custody i believe yeah
where was the warning shot like next to
the girl's ear no i think i think he i
think he [ __ ] up i think he just like
was griffin or something like that and
just like not good trigger control doing
that whole get off my property and then
the it was funny because when the black
dad like stepped back he like
accidentally stepped on some flowers and
he's like you're stepping on my floss
like as if it was like a malicious snake
like he didn't just pull out a gun and
the dude was like true yo what the [ __ ]
he's like waiting for like a reason he's
like my draining
geraniums
that's the situation now and they they
don't know if it was true that some kid
got jumped or anything but [ __ ] some
kids need to get spanked man
but you know but look that goes right
back to the parent that's that's what it
is yeah ignorant appearance bro it's
like dude you're gonna have a lot of
ignorance and people get like all raised
you're not gonna ever you're not gonna
ever get rid of it you're gonna always
have people who are gonna be ignorant
like that and do stupid stuff or say
stuff and you teach your kid that cause
kids don't know yeah black and white i
don't even know i was really black bro
until i moved to texas and went to
school and i got jumped when i lived in
galveston but some white kids called me
i was like damn what is that you know
fighting this [ __ ] getting jumped and
another black kid said hey man watch out
these kids by the way the race i'm like
what is that i didn't even know i was
black how old are you
first grade
first grade first grade [ __ ] i got
jumped i got jumped by some kids on the
way home but then the apartment complex
i lived in one of my best friends was a
little white kid no you know little
dirty white kid and we were buddies
little dirty white kids you know don't
shoot kyle right around
my little buddy but his i've never heard
his mom say the word n-word or his dad
you know and they were they were still
like you know i'm in technology
hillbillies you know i mean this country
we're not rich either we're poor living
in a little little dirt little apartment
complex but
so it's not everybody but you're gonna
have ignorance and some people just
ignorant and you gotta blame the parents
right look at the dad he's a [ __ ]
idiot come on yeah i mean that's true
there's your example right there he was
probably paranoid man he's scared as
[ __ ] he probably told his kid to go do
that [ __ ] yeah exactly
why would the kid lead out where are you
gonna get the where from yeah it's not
just sitting over i mean obviously take
this go into them oh no more black
people house and go start whipping some
[ __ ]
boy
we're gonna show them
goddamn we're gonna show him he's like
all right they're gonna learn today who
jeffrey is
we have a six shooter right here yeah
yeah yeah bring him back here boy lead
him back leave him back
you got it hey low-key kind of a crazy
theory but like could be true yeah it is
it's crazy sounds like i've heard it
before though sounds like it's happening
oh bait and switch yeah you know
bring the bait out there boy
it's just a more creative bait yeah
exactly with the whip he's like yeah why
do i do it do i do okay
[Music]
how do you know to do that yeah crazy
i don't even have a horse he has a whip
yeah exactly yeah and they and then
again when the cops came to uh
investigate they didn't confiscate the
whip and a bunch of people were mad
about them
don't let them keep the wind put in
evidence
i think they were more [ __ ] like
concerned about the gunshot down
yeah
they're going to go right back to the
wheel what about the whip though
see that right there whoo gun versus
that right there
bring back memories i don't know i've
seen a lot of movies where the whip beat
the gun
[Laughter]
which one is the more lethal weapon man
i don't know yeah depending on same who
it could have been a case of mistaken
identity maybe that they thought you
know that or that boy thought that that
kid was the one who jumped him so he
went to the wrong house yeah i don't
know but that's just bad parenting too
though it's bad parenting for sure it's
also a terrible way to like
be responsible for your kid when they
show up they're just like oh let me
escalate the situation with a gun
let me make this even worse yeah we had
a um like a hoa halloween party uh
in our community and then like all the
parents are hanging out and all the kids
are hanging out and there's like this
little like i don't know like 11 or 12
year old white boy
running around with like this random
hammer that's part of his costume oh
it's like it's soft though it was like a
real hand it's like a soft hammer and
he's whacking all the kids oh and he's
whacking all the kids and then like me
my wife geo and my other friend silent
mike we're just standing there like man
this kid's a [ __ ] nuisance and he's
going around and then so mike he's just
friendly so he's like i'll just go play
with the kids and maybe like establish
some order and then this guy comes and
he starts whacking himself mike on the
head too boy and then so i was like i
gotta like put a stop to this so i was
like i did it in a play way i was like
you're under arrest so i grabbed the
hammer i ripped it out of his hands and
i put him on the ground like this and he
was like
and then jill's like this is the
wrestler he can't be doing that he's
like he's white and i was like nah this
age minorities
i was like i got all the voices
i got a seat at the hoa yeah now where
were the kids parents
so like uh in the beginning we would
like try to like move our whole group so
that the uh the kids move over and then
you see the kid um
kid would be a hammer kid would be in
the view of the mom and when the mom
would see him she's like
the fact that you have to do that
so we're trying to like like subtly like
go hey man you're [ __ ] cute nudge her
into parenting a little bit yeah yeah
but she's just like oh there he goes
again this is crazy i don't know what to
do see little toby with his hammer yeah
like you said you got her and then her
where's her man at he's probably some
dude eating a a a vegan burrito
you know what i mean pray weenie vegan
burrito
lil weenie bro
[Laughter]
telling you we should go places you
better not man you better not i you know
dude you act a fool like that my mom man
come on dude
it's like your kid acting like that and
it's like the mom and then where the
dude the daddy yeah because you know
some parents i used to coach like all
these kids and some kids would just be
wild and and then their parents would be
on the side and they go yeah whatever
you know they'll give a [ __ ] you ever
try to just spank them some parents just
look at their kid like hey
and they'll just look at them and
they'll go okay sorry and they'll just
stop completely yeah
yeah that's all that's how it was right
you know you don't see that much anymore
man you come in here man i've seen some
people in their parents and dad's little
dude but pops ain't no punk like dude oh
it's my dad bro yeah yeah
yeah i'm like hey how are you doing
sounds like okay yeah where you guys
going tonight okay man you got to be
honest what time all right yeah man i
mean there's a respect factor don't
forget your win
can't leave the houses out here this
little vietnamese dads oh they're like
scary as hell but they're like tiny yeah
part of the guys scared of guys
daddy no joke
chop your head or something man i mean
no joke you know big families too big
family but all everybody's in line ain't
no [ __ ] in there man no [ __ ] you
never hear nobody talk back never bro
that's i never heard that but like
something like you said these dudes
that's just weak dads weak man dad's
brother you have a boy week yeah cause
you ain't scared of your dad it's all
wrong
you know and the thing you're doing in
public yeah yeah public display like
that who allows the kids to do that like
you said it's like dude where's the
order at bart had a really good dad that
was really good at that uh discipline
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
which one's better trauma and
traumatized with order
or free and you know you know it's crazy
so my guys beat the [ __ ] out of me right
and then now like i tell my kid to just
like go to timeout or something right
he's like
look how sad he is
[Laughter]
my kid is like in the corner
like this and he'll come with like a
tissue and [ __ ] like wipe wipe his
teeth oh my dad are making him soft
i'm like what the [ __ ] were you like
where the [ __ ] was that when i needed
said what the [ __ ] is going on dude
that's his grandfather privileges he
could just like because when he missed
behavior she's like oh it's your problem
now
yeah you know you know at the end like
you said though
even like i should say like my homeboy
said like sometimes you need that good
ass whooping because you got to
establish a sense of like it's love but
it's respect and you know that there's a
consequence so it taught you but at the
same time you're not in prison you're
not running around doing stupid [ __ ] you
know that there's a value system there
that you can go back to man my dad
didn't play this [ __ ] you know so you
can fall back on that well you don't
have that to fall back on and these kids
who run around right now just having no
no sense of consequence because their
dad never whooped that ass and i'm not
saying that that's the way you don't
beat your kids but you have to establish
that there's some order and that man you
know what i'm not going to mess up
because i don't want to have to face my
dad
your dad should be more scary than
police yeah true in a way that is how it
was growing up you didn't care what the
principal said what the teacher said
just don't call my dad
jack comes home i was happy when the
police came out ethan allen i was like
now my dad can't beat my ass
give me a ride home
that just took off
[Music]
you